aïe aïe la vie dure dur dur la vie du
rhin il y à pied à cheval ou en voiture
en route pour de nouvelles aventures
j'ai pris un train en partance un train
de voyageurs qui traversent la france
les par ailleurs j'ai pris un train vers
20,2 m
pour mon année
au petit bonheur un pied à cheval ou en
voiture vers du welz aventure
la vidéo dure dure la vie du rail ap un
cheval ou en voiture en route pour de
nouvelles aventures
chacun bookeen son magazine un pédicure
matt mes chaussures le bruit des rails
horizontale terre cela nuit à l'infini
un homme d'affaires sommes mal comme une
casserole et son voisin rouspète
derrière ses lunettes
le militaire si rob burger
là le contrôleur sous sa visière et
lumière d'une ville des films comme des
lucioles au ras du sol une dame sort un
caniche de sa valise un mangeurs de
sandwichs en maintenant 11 h maison aie
aie aie aie l'ami du milieu rap
à pied à cheval ou en voiture
à
on vient de passer sous une montagne
une étudiante et peluches une banane la
veilleuse en ma ligne de mire j'arrive
pas à dormir le long de ce chemin de fer
entre souvenirs est de venir on ne
revient pas en arrière quand on s'aime
il faut partir la vidéo dure dure la vie
du rail à pied à cheval ou en voiture
une toute nouvelle aventure pour tous
de te jeter
peut- e teu teu teu teu teu teu
de teu teu teu
le 2 février un train sans
correspondance un train de voyageurs
qui traverse la france pour aller voir
ailleurs ou nurul la diligence comme un
bandit sur la paille
j'ai pris mon mal en patience
dur dur la vie du rail à pied à cheval
ou en voiture en route pour de nouvelles
aventures à pied un cheval ou en voiture
en route pour de nouvelles toujours plus
belles éventuelles sous virtuel aventure
que le 2e tour
nous vous rappelons qu'un bar est à
votre disposition voitures neuves et
nous signalons également que vous devez
absolument vous munir de votre type de
transport lors de vos déplacements dans
ce train merci mon voyage je veux te te
te
où
de teu teu teu teu teu
doudou 12
tout le temps de vous
la lutte